en las calles de gaza velan a un
periodista de la emisora laxa de hamás
you said abu hussein murió durante un
bombardeo nocturno mientras los
sobrevivientes asimilan los daños en
medio del dolor
ellos no estaban luchando que estaban
preparando el almuerzo en la cocina
cuando el golpe cayó sobre la cocina y
los mató y los quemó que ha hecho una
niña de tres años para merecer móvil
quemada viva en la cocina mientras que
mi hermano y su esposa estaban hechos
pedazos en otros países árabes mostraron
su solidaridad hacia el pueblo palestino
hoy enviamos un mensaje claro al mundo
de que el pueblo palestino no está solo
y que los estamos apoyando su causa es
nuestra causa los derechos de los
palestinos son los derechos de los
tunecinos la sangre palestina y la
tunecina es una y no olvidaremos esta
historia mientras en israel no hay
intenciones debes escalar los ataques
hacia la franja de gaza- la comunidad
internacional pide al gobierno israelí
que baje la intensidad de la ofensiva
pero la lectura del primer ministro es
distinta dijo que está determinado
continuar hasta garantizar la paz para
el presidente de la autoridad palestina
israel está cometiendo crímenes de
guerra y aunque las autoridades del
grupo hamas prevén que en pocos días
existan las condiciones para un cese del
fuego
los bombardeos israelíes
lanzamiento de cohetes por parte de
hamás continuaron durante el día y la
noche del miércoles